10 Comic Book Characters That Need Their Own
Movies ASAP
Comic book movies are incredibly popular right
now and some of the most iconic characters
in Marvel and DC history have been given the
Hollywood treatment.
Superman, Batman, Spider-Man, Hulk, Iron Man,
Captain America and Thor are just some of
the characters to have starred in their own
movies, while the likes of Wonder Woman, Doctor
Strange, the Flash and Black Panther will
be following suit soon.But there are still
countless characters - both heroes and villains
- who haven't yet been considered for a solo
movie outing that definitely deserve one.
It seems a shame that the Man of Steel, the
Dark Knight, the Webbed Wonder and the Green
Goliath have been given multiple opportunities
while other equally deserving characters miss
out completely.With that in mind, here are
ten comic book characters that deserve their
own movies ASAP.
Black Widow
If there's one existing comic book movie character
who hasn't had their own movie yet, but who
definitely deserves one, it has to be Black
Widow.
Scarlett Johansson has portrayed the character
brilliantly since 2010's Iron Man 2 and has
subsequently appeared in four more movies
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Natasha Romanoff has such an interesting history,
but it's only briefly been touched upon in
the movies.
A solo movie would give audiences the opportunity
to see more of it, while getting more kick-ass
Black Widow action - something nobody would
complain about (especially not the guys).
The Joker
As far as comic book characters go, there's
really nobody more interesting than the Joker.
He's undoubtedly the most popular villain
in comic book history and he always garners
a lot of interest when he's portrayed in a
movie - so why not give him one of his own?
The likes of Jack Nicholson and Heath Ledger
have already played the character, and Jared
Leto is set to do so in Suicide Squad, but
a movie that focuses solely on him as the
lead character could potentially be exceptional.
A detailed look into his twisted mind and
what drives him to torment Batman would really
immerse fans.
And seeing him put his intricate but totally
crazy plots together is always a real treat.
If Leto proves popular as the Clown Prince
of Gotham, DC and Warner Brothers should definitely
consider making him the lead in a future movie.
Doctor Fate
DC movies are yet to truly delve in to the
world of magic.
And although Suicide Squad will introduce
the Enchantress to the DCEU, she is hardly
a flagship character.
Doctor Fate is exactly that - he's the biggest
magical gun in the DC universe - and it's
a shame he hasn't been considered for a movie
to date.
With his Marvel counterpart Doctor Strange
getting a movie of his own, it's only right
that the character who wears the powerful
Helmet of Nabu gets one too - whether it be
the Kent Nelson version, the Hector Hall version,
or otherwise.
It would surely be a visual treat - just like
the Doctor Strange movie looks like being
- and Fate would definitely be a welcome addition
to the live action Justice League.
Namor the Sub-Mariner
Namor the Sub-Mariner is a classic Marvel
character who has been around for as long
as the company itself.
If anyone deserves a movie of his own, it's
Namor - and it's unforgivable that he hasn't
been given one yet.
Of course, he was hinted at back in Iron Man
2, when a S.H.I.E.L.D.
map appeared to show his home kingdom of Atlantis,
but the Easter egg hasn't been followed up.
However, now that his DC counterpart Aquaman
is getting his own movie, Marvel Studios should
undoubtedly follow suit.
He's interesting because he's incredibly powerful
and his moral alignment is unclear.
A movie with him as the star would undoubtedly
be unique and well worth a watch.
Martian Manhunter
The Martian Manhunter, J'onn J'onzz, has long
been a key member of the Justice League in
the comic books - but it would appear that
he is missing from the DC live action movie
universe, which is a complete travesty.
He's an awesome character who absolutely deserves
a movie of his own - just like Superman, Batman,
Wonder Woman, the Flash and Cyborg are getting
in the DCEU.
The character's backstory differs from timeline
to timeline in the comics, but he is always
from Mars, always has the physical attributes
to match Superman, can always shapeshift,
always has telepathic powers and can always
phase through objects.
He's incredibly interesting and it would be
truly great to see him given a solo movie.
Doctor Doom
As far as Marvel supervillains go, there are
none more versatile and interesting than Doctor
Doom - and he definitely deserves his own
movie.
Fox Studios have adapted the character twice
on film already - as Fantastic Four movie
villains in each instance - but both adaptations
were awful, and Julian McMahon and Toby Kebbell
have a lot to answer for as a result.
Setting a movie in Doom's fictional home country
of Latveria and following his evil exploits
as he tried to take over the world would make
fantastic viewing.
He's an iconic comic book character who is
a scientific genius, a mystical expert and
a very underrated physical threat, and a movie
focusing on a faithful adaptation of the character
would be most welcome.
She-Hulk
The comic book movie world is desperately
lacking in female-led movies - especially
female-led movies starring extremely powerful
characters - so a She-Hulk solo movie would
be a fantastic idea for Marvel Studios to
produce.
She-Hulk is Jennifer Walters - cousin of Bruce
Banner - who developed similar powers to the
Hulk when Banner provided his blood for her
for a transfusion after she was shot.
It would be seriously cool to see a muscular
green female character displaying the kind
of strength we've seen from Hulk so often
on the big screen.
That's really all the reasoning needed to
make such a movie a reality.
Nova
If Guardians of the Galaxy proved one thing,
it's that Marvel Studios can nail movies based
on space-based heroes - so a Nova movie would
surely be fantastic.
The Nova Corps were already introduced in
the aforementioned Guardians of the Galaxy
movie, but seeing their most famous human
member - Richard Rider - starring in his own
movie would be great.
Such a movie has long been rumoured, but it
has yet to either be produced or scheduled.
The likes of Nathan Fillion have been linked
to the titular role, but it would be a brilliant
space-epic no matter who took it on.
Think DC's Green Lantern movie, but if it
was actually in capable hands.
A truly exciting prospect.
Lobo
2016's Deadpool movie was absolutely fantastic
- and the closest thing DC could do to replicate
the tone is produce a movie based on Lobo.
The space mercenary and bounty hunter is also
known as The Ultimate Bastich, The Main Man
and The 'Bo Master Frag - all because of his
bad-ass attitude and huge personality.
A Lobo solo outing would be gory, funny and
irreverant - just like Deadpool - and he would
be an awesome addition to DC's live action
line-up.
The best thing about this is that it's rumoured
to be in the pipeline.
Can you imagine The Scourge o' the Cosmos
going toe-to-toe with Henry Cavill's Superman
or Gal Gadot's Wonder Woman?
It would be incredible!
Harley Quinn
Why should superheroes get all the glory?
This year's Suicide Squad will see a supervillain
team headlining a comic book movie for the
first time ever, but supervillain solo movies
don't really happen - and that's a crying
shame.
Early reactions from screenings of the Suicide
Squad movie suggest that Margot Robbie's Harley
Quinn is the standout star.
If that's really the case, she should definitely
be given a movie of her own.
She's a quirky, fun, sexy and interesting
character with a fantastic ongoing comic,
so there's definitely an audience for her,
and Margot Robbie's star has never shone brighter.
A movie that looks into her origins - in which
she was driven insane by the Joker, but also
became his lover and accomplice - would be
awesome.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 comic book
characters that need their own movies ASAP.
Do you agree with any of these?
Which other comic book characters should be
given their own movies?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.